the glamorous scrambled eggs we're gonna
flambe now that time of day again this
time to be scrambled eggs of worms
now I'm gonna marinate them clean the
property with some one Bisco that's
sterilizes them okay I get rid of any
dirt okay now from there literally
swallow them around wash them that
literally sterilizing them from there a
little bit of chilli over the cord made
this thing so local touch of pink salt
now from the season touchable in its
time frying off those chosen corner
Thanks
now let's head out
driver but from there get those things
crispy they really need to be crispy
dingo
is not
no talk
touch the seasoning again
Chili's in me glamorous yes scrambled
egg I were me see
yeah for my sushi fur
beautiful lightly seasoned on top give
that a little stir
yeah 30 seconds on a little bit butter
what it goes in touch
a little touch milk first and then
beautiful hmm scrambled egg out of worm
a these high-altitude eggs let's go mmm
if it's a he'd yours
mm-hmm
yeah Rico scrambled eggs and Englund
lovely let me finish with the worms oh
gosh yes now you hold on please
something I'll be waiting to do just in
mando come here yeah oh no no no come on
ready right let's go please
spoon okay make sure we get it well so
long please go wait so I can see there
yeah yeah whatever today my friend oh
come on there's a word on there do you
see it it's right there no I clean my
nose
you made it actually really good it
doesn't taste too bad well done you know
what you're doing an amazing end to for
me from a chef Manabu an amazing crew
the best week on how high-altitude
cooking and more importantly scrambled
eggs with worms done let me know in the
comments what you think of that amazing
scrambled egg dish and if you missed
uncharted trust me you can watch it on
the link below or on the NatGeo app